humans seem to
be pretty happy when they form
communities uh uh however you define
that it's a romantic partnership family
communities some communities people
people are miserable in other
communities so the nature of the
community matters right we know this we
know that that some bondings are not
healthy and not good for the individuals
involved and and they don't thrive
um so i i absolutely i mean i'm a lover
not a fighter right so i'm a huge
believer in love
the whole philosophy i think is that is
a love-based philosophy i fight in order
to love right so it's it's love is love
is at the core of all of this and it's
it's it's it's a love of of life it's a
love of of the world out there and it's
a love of other people because they
represent a value to you
so the stickiness is there it's it's you
know my point is a it should be chosen
it should be consciously chosen and and
this is i'm put aside the state forget
the state for a minute forget forget cos
and forget all that
what i would encourage individuals to do
and this is where you know i'm i'm not
primarily a political you know
interested in politics although
i sent to talk most about that i'm
primarily interested in human beings and
how they live in in a sense and morality
and what i would urge individuals to do
is to think about their relationships to
choose the best relationships possible
but to seek out great relationships
because other human beings are an
immense value to us
and and
you know when i write
you know maybe you don't quoted this or
not but all right that
you know about the trade of principle
and trading
you know it's easy and and and obvious
to think of it as a materialistic kind
of thing you know i get you know i i i
do the chose this day and my wife does
the shows the other day and we're
trading but trading is much more subtle
than that and much more can be much more
spiritual than that it's about
the the the the the trading in in
emotions it's about it's about the the
way one uh sees each other what one gets
from one another i think friendship is a
form of trade now i know that that seems
to make it material but i don't i don't
think it's of trade as a material thing
but
friendship is incredibly important in
life love is incredibly important in
life
you know
having having a group of friends is
incredibly important all of these are
sticky and important okay how can i try
to be eloquent on this so
if you give people freedom
if you give people politics yeah well
not politics relations relations uh
relationships so
this is interesting because we have an
interesting dynamic going on here in
terms of beliefs they're differing and
so there's interesting overlaps but
there's a worry if you look at human
history and you study the lessons of
history and you look at modern society
if you give people freedom in terms of
stickiness and human relations and so on
full
like if you not give people freedom
emphasize
freedom as the highest ideal
you start getting more tinder
online dating the sticking is dissolved
just like in chemistry you start to have
a gas versus a liquid right that that's
the way so you have to what you have to
study
what actually happens if you emphasize
that um
the stickiness the bonds of humans
is holding you back the exercise of
voluntary choice
is the highest ideal
the danger of that is for that to be
implemented or interpreted in certain
kinds of ways by us flawed humans that
are not i mean you could say we're
perfectly reasonable and rational we can
think through all of our decisions but
really i mean especially you're young
you get horny you make decisions that
are suboptimal perhaps so the the point
is you have to look at reality
of when you emphasize different things
so when when you talk about what is
the ideal life what is the ideal
relations you have to also think like
what are you emphasizing i think you
both agree on what's important that
community can be important that freedom
is important but what are you
emphasizing and you're really
emphasizing the individual and
you're emphasizing uh you're wrong
you're emphasizing
more of the community of the family of
the stickiness of the nation
well look i don't want to deny the place
of the individual i i think that
uh
that
there really is a very great
change in civilization
when the books of moses
announce that
the individual is created in the image
of god
that that's a step that's
as far as we know without pre president
before that in history
and uh to a very large degree i mean one
of the kind of unspoken
uh things going on is that that uh euron
and i really do agree on all sorts of
things i i think in part because because
we're we're both jewish and and he said
you just say you're on
basically moses yesterday
no i said he was channeling moses but
that's still in my book you know that
that's still pretty pretty that's a
compliment that's pretty good
that
for me that's a compliment and we'll
talk about this a little bit just for
the listener just so they
they know iran amongst many things we'll
talk about the virtue of nationalism but
you're also a religious scholar of sorts
or at least
leverage
the bible for much not much but some of
the wisdom in your life
look the way that euron looks at
enlightenment or maybe at iran that that
that's that's the way that i see the uh
hebrew scripture and and the tradition
that comes from it uh it has the same
kind of place in my life and i i just
i don't know how much we want to
want to explore it but i i i think that
uh that
the agreement that we do have about the
positive value of
the creative individual the positive
value of the individual's um desire to
improve the world and and and and
in my book that means
including his or her desire to improve
his family his his his tribe his
congregation his nation
but but it still comes from this kind of
for you know what your own call
selfishness
the the desire to make things better for
yourself
you